[Music]
ladies and gentlemen this fellow is one
of People magazine's sexiest men alive
you were we just saw why that what's
about that that's a high honor that was
a very high honor I I was astonished to
get that news and it must be said that I
was the people's magazine's sexiest man
of the year mustache addition that
mustache to be fair to my friend Shannon
yeah it was quite taken aback by that
information what's good it is an
impressive stache I call it a stache
what's now I know that you led a big
part of the Movember campaign for men to
promote their mustaches that's over now
you got to shave it to keep it it is
well I do it you know this mustache is a
bit of a curse I shave it every morning
and it we trim it three times a day
second breakfast lunch time and then tea
time and then by the time I get up in
the morning it's about down to my chin
so it's it seems you know it seems like
a blessing but it's it's a lot to handle
I'm surprised you don't don't suffocate
in the night it's it's tough megan has
special breathing lacerations over my
uterus that poor woman is generous I
also want to pay you a compliment I
don't say this often I don't think I've
ever said it you have a manly smell
you have a manly smell what's your
what's your secret don't you get that
Andy yeah he does some kind of Cologne
or something it's singing just that's
all my natural Musk just a precious your
natural it's your natural Musk that's I
have two secrets every morning I take a
little bit of bacon grease out of my
breakfast and just dab it a little bit
behind the ears it drives them wild and
then I you mean Ravens editorial the all
of the vermin that go crazy for my Musk
yeah and then I rub some of that grease
in the latissimus area on my back and
that promotes healthy back hair growth
there you have it
God you the ultimate man in so many ways
now we both participated in a charity a
terrific charity night of too many stars
for that I did a stunt for them I
cornrowed my hair and had a fake tan for
a night and we raised some money you
stripped for that cause that's direct I
took my clothes off you took the clothes
off and it was was that released online
was that well it turned out to be an
ill-conceived notion to try and raise
money by people paying to see me take my
clothes off
as people donated more and more amounts
they could see more of my garment be
removed and things petered out rather
quickly
no I don't mean that figuratively no no
you would never you would never do that
I've never got close to that point yeah
I think we have a clip here if you
stripping quite shocking let's take a
look trees you've all been very good
little donors get ready to see some
nipples
[Applause]
[Applause]
go on get some overtime you set that
charity back eight years several donors
ask for their money back
[Laughter]